z'amis si vous venez nous rejoindre il
ya également deux mascottes qui est ici
je me rends bien les appels masque lover
dans cette mascotte ya une personne qui
est venue dire quelque chose à quelqu'un
de l'amitié de l'amitié de l'amitié nous
avons déjà eu deux indices ouais nos
amis job et elles se créent mais s'est
trompé skins
cette personne est célèbre et c'est une
femme elle est très célèbre très célèbre
alors est elle venue pour vous
michel même plus loin je peux plus pour
vous sait-on jamais une cinquième femme
pour vous ils n'ont non non non vous
êtes déjà de petites sommes même pour
vous oui oui ah oui abat-jour vaudois où
pourtant commencé de trop mathieu pour
vous peut-être mais c'est une femme
laissée l'animateur va fonctionner
exactement
voilà et c'est l'animateur est ce que
quelqu'un autour de la table a une idée
de la personne et de qui il s'agit au
début j'y reviens vous dire certains ont
la mémoire courte
certainement plus que ce qui est dans
l'eure c'est pas à toi ben reprend
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
carla et moi je vais pas tarder à me
faire chier
[Rires]
[Musique]
fatou allô allô fatou
[Applaudissements]
qu'est ce qu'un confrère ouais tu viens
quand tu me moucher les mais je crois
que commente un numéro est en tout cas
ceux numérotés chef attend quoi moi
qu'est-ce qu'ils vont gaiement boddaert
autant mal mais merde
coderre on t'aime et tu seras l'époque
jeudi prochain dans la grosse rigolade
mais avec gros bisous à vous je t'aime
mon frère des meilleurs
couderc à des numéros
je vous rappel c'est le seul quel numéro
et fatou apparemment cru que c'était la
prochaine vote et s'embrasser sera pas
tout ce qu'ils écoutent et miel même
quand tu as entendu le halo alors je
vais pas aller mal et chérie la mascotte
tatchou oui d'ailleurs je vous le dis
cette mascotte c'est quelqu'un de connu
c'est quelqu'un dont je suis fan
voyons c est une personne en plus que je
trouve extrêmement belle je vous dis que
j'étais petit je n'étais pas grand je
n'étais pas grand merci
les super ordinateurs ainsi pas nous
manquer et la famille je vais aller la
chercher elle habite à levallois au nom
de la patrie
c'est une phase assez magnifique stade
attendait cheval est lâché
ouais pouvoirs avec mme chan
[Applaudissements]
vous avez dit pas non plus ma part est
tombée à trapani malawi un poste qu'on
sorte de cette personne
ebony à la des cheveux chaque personne
est venu pour un petit tonnes cette
année venus pour un petit soeur et moi
ma chérie là on a donné à voir un dessin
il dit chaque personne est venu pour un
petit homme
cette personne elle est là pour vous
faudra un petit talent de l'ombre cette
personne est là pour vous oh là là et
cette personne c'est ac c'est qu'ils
mangeaient pas donner de noms
c'est c'est
vale à 3 lehmann fois le plus petit des
scores
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
l'ancien protégé de fabien lecoeuvre est
tout cas tu es magnifique vraiment merci
te le dis merci ça va mieux alors
racontez nous pourquoi tu aimé parce que
y en tous cas rien parce qu'on a une
vraie histoire d'amitié ouais c'est ça
depuis depuis très très longtemps et on
a on a beaucoup partagé de choses
ensemble
en tout bien tout honneur bien que si je
te mets c'est ça qu'est ce qu'on voulait
dire c'est vraiment là lui et c'est une
vraie histoire d'amour mais à d'amitié
amoureuse
c'est à dire six ans roma s'est passé
huit ans collés ensemble n'avaient que
tout pensé vous étiez ensemble en fait
non oui non pas du tout parce qu'elle
était amoureuse d'un garçon moi j'étais
un bon rythme et patient est mais quand
j'ai été libre après elle était pâle et
quand elle était pâle et moi j'étais
libre c'est des histoires classiques 1
et on était surtout frères et soeurs est
très très compliqué voilà quoi on a fait
sept ans beaucoup de portes ce soir
non mais c'est vrai c'est à dire qu'on
en a tellement envie qu'une chose
ensemble
c'est que
c'est vrai que là on a des beaux gosses
j'en étais toujours toujours ensemble on
a vraiment des jeux l'avait sur le dos
tout le temps mais c'est vrai ça l'était
pas très haute en fin septembre dos mais
magnifique ballade là on avait beau nom
mais c'est ça me fait très plaisir en
tout cas parce qu'on s'est pas vu depuis
un moment parce qu'elle du sud et puis
non vraiment ça me touche beaucoup
ah bon ça franchement
[Applaudissements]
je l'admets très choqués les magnifiques
la suivre elle sert était magnifique non
mais ah bah oui je comprends maintenant
créer mais c'est ça à ce que je n'étais
partie un jour aux antilles ensemble
tous les deux pour travailler ouais on
est partis en mer un bandonéon sur toi
sur un bateau non en fait l'histoire
c'est qu'on était sur une plage et on
sait passer de la crème solaire est
alors coiffé tout en glisse parce que de
la crème solaire de loin pansement se
caresser le dos au mur d'eau qui avaient
des amis proches de mon de mon ex mari
ont dit oui à mes enfants que je salue
on dit reset car ils vous ce cas là je
alors on en a eu quelques scènes de
ménages oui c'est yves suite à ça et
c'est vrai qu'il ya eu des rumeurs mais
tu sais dans l'amitié les dents alors
que rien de tout cela n'a rien rien en
tout cas n en est rien ça m'a fait très
plaisir de te voir ému comme sa douche
là tu seras le 9 mai à marcinelle en
belgique pour un concert pour disney tu
fais toujours des taux promo pour les
enfants avec la fabuleuse histoire de
douche car en octobre sortira un album
hommage à ton papa gianni esposito le
poète éternelle oui hommage au poète
éternel j'ai la chance de monter sur
scène avec un roland romanelli et ma
maman pascale petit qui viendra sûr sûr
sûr le spectacle d'hier quelques poèmes
ceux de mon père ce que j'écris aussi et
puis toute l'année je chante mes
aventures de disney de l'époque pour
narrer inversée avec fabien avait perdu
tic et tac
d'abord il ya ce faire on était parti
avant avec tik et tak et puis on les
avait perdus dans le traîneau et on les
avait oubliés d'entrée d'eau on était
descendu on aurait pu penser et en j'ai
dû arrêter
j'ai dû arrêter tous les traîneaux non
mais sa droite et anecdotes
[Applaudissements]
j'étais enfermé on y entend des
visiteurs allez je peux aller c'est vrai
j'ai fait le père noël on écoutait tout
va bien merci
[Applaudissements]